i
a
españa es el país del mundo con más
artistas condenados a penas de prisión
por lo que dicen en sus obras
concretamente 14 esto es lo que revela
el informe sobre el estado actual de la
libertad artística en el mundo y que
hace referencia a datos de 2019 pero que
en el caso de españa cuenta con casos
que fueron muy sonados también en 2018
como particularmente el del rapero by
tonic que en 2018 fue condenado a tres
años y medio de prisión por
enaltecimiento del terrorismo injurias
contra la corona y amenazas y cabe
destacar que val tonic era prácticamente
desconocido antes de su primera
detención fue en ese momento cuando
estalló su popularidad que creció más
aún cuando justo antes de entrar en
prisión
el rapero decidió exiliarse a bélgica
donde continúa todavía a día de hoy
pendiente de si la justicia belga decide
extraditarlo o no tal y como pide la
justicia española
[Música]
después de españa irán es el país con
mayor número de artistas encarcelados
según la organización no gubernamental
free bus que habla que 11 escritores
activistas y también director de cine en
este caso
mohammad rasoulof fueron condenados en
el último año en el último caso el
director de cine por hacer propaganda
contra el estado es muy interesante
porque antes de recibir el llamado a
pagar su condenar a su luz había logrado
sacar clandestinamente del país su
última producción de disney vilo no hay
que ganó el máximo galardón en el
festival de cine de berlín para más allá
de los números de personas que van a la
cárcel en la presión que sufren los
artistas los cineastas por ejemplo
tienen que mandar su guión y su
producción final para recibir una
aprobación para ser mostrada en los
cines lo que ha llevado a que muchos en
el pasado dejen de trabajar en el país
pero la mayor presión está en las
mujeres cantantes que tienen prohibido
cantar en solitario desde la revolución
islámica en 1979
[Música]
con nueve entre rejas turquía está entre
los países del mundo que más artistas
tienen ahora mismo encarcelados por
haber hecho durante su carrera arte
muchos son muchos de ellos son kurdos y
son representados después del golpe de
estado 2016 por ejemplo uno de los
últimos entrar a la cárcel fue el
director de una obra de teatro kurda que
quería representarse en estambul en
kurdo el director fue detenido durante
unas horas luego después fue liberado
pero el caso más paradigmático de lo que
es el artista en turquía es el del
rapero es el el más famoso de turquía
2018 fue encarcelado por promover las
drogas y estuvo en cárcel durante un año
en prisión preventiva después sin ningún
tipo de prueba fue el liberado y ahora
vive en alemania